Put God first.
God first in every thing you do,
everything that you think you see in me,
everything that I've accomplished,
everything that you think I have and I
have a few things.
Everything that I have is by the grace
of God,
understand that it's a gift.
40 years ago,
March 27th,
1975 it was 40 years ago,
just this past march,
I was flunking out of college at a 1.7
grade point average.
I hope none of you can relate
at a 1.7 grade point average.
I was sitting in my mother's beauty
shop.
They still call it beauty shops now when
they call it now.
Yeah,
I'll sit in the beauty parlor.
I was sitting in my mother's beauty
pollock and I'm looking in the mirror
and I see behind me this woman under the
dryer and every time she looked up,
she,
every time I looked up,
she was looking at me,
just look at me in the eye and I didn't
know who she was and I said,
you know,
she said,
somebody give me a pen,
give me a pencil.
I have a prophecy.
March 27 1975 she said,
boy,
you are going to travel the world and
speak to millions of people.
Am I a flunked out of college?
I'm thinking about joining the army.
I didn't know what I was going to do and
she's telling me I'm going to travel
there world and speak to millions of
people.
Well,
I have traveled the world
and I have spoken to millions of people,
but that's not the most important thing
to success that I had.
The most important thing is that what
she taught me,
what she told me that day has stayed
with me.
Me,
since I've been protected,
I've been directed,
I've been correct.
I've kept God in my life and has kept me
humble.
I didn't always stick with him,
but he always stuck with me.
So stick with them in everything you do.
If you think you want to do what you
think I've done,
then do what I've done and stick with
God.
Number two,
fail big.
That's right.
Fail big.
Today's the beginning of the rest of
your life and it can be,
it's good.
Can Be very frightening.
It's a new world out there.
It's a mean world out there and you only
live once.
So do what you feel passionate about,
passionate about.
Take chances professionally.
Don't be afraid to fail.
There's an old Iq test was nine dots and
you had to draw five lines with the
pencil within these nine dots without
lifting the pencil.
The only way to do it was to go outside
box.
So don't be afraid to go outside the
Don't be afraid to think outside the
box.
Don't be afraid to fail,
big to dream big.
But remember,
dreams without goals are just dreams and
they ultimately fuel disappointment.
So have dreams but have goals,
life goals,
yearly goals,
monthly goals,
daily goals.
I tried to give myself a goal every day.
Time is just to not curse somebody out.
Simple goals,
but have goals
and understand that to achieve these
goals,
you must apply discipline
and consistency
in order to achieve your goals.
You must apply discipline which you
already done,
and consistency every day,
not just one Tuesday and miss a few
days.
You have to work at it every day.
You have to plan every day.
You've heard the saying,
we don't plan to fail.
We fail to plan hard work works.
Working really hard is what successful
people do.
And in this text tweet torque world that
you've grown up in,
remember,
just because you're doing a lot more
doesn't mean you're getting a lot more
done.
Remember that just because you're doing
a lot more
doesn't mean you're getting a lot more
done.
Don't confuse movement
with progress.
My mother told me she,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause you can run in place all the time
and never get anywhere.
So continue to strive and can you to
have goals continue to progress.
Number three,
you'll never see a u haul behind a
hearse.
I'll say it again.
You'll never see a u haul behind a
hearse.
I don't care how much money you make,
you can't take it with you via Gypson.
[inaudible],
Dryden.
They got robbed as all nate got.
You can't take it with you and it's not
how much you have.
It's what you do with what you have.
We all have different talents.
Some of you will be doctors,
some lawyers,
some scientists,
some educated,
some nurses,
some teaching.
So I'm preachers.
The most selfish thing you can do in
this world
is helps someone else.
Why is it selfish?
Because the gratification,
the goodness that comes to you,
the good feeling,
the good feeling that I get from helping
others.
Nothing's better than that.
Well,
one or two things,
but nothing's better than that.
Not Not Jewelry,
not big house.
I have not cars,
but it's the joy.
That's where the joy is in helping
others.
That's where the success is in helping
Finally,
I pray that
you put your slippers way under the bed
tonight
so that when you wake up in the morning,
you have to get on your knees
to reach them.
And why did you win?
While you're down there say thank you
for grace.
Thank you for mercy.
Thank you for understanding.
Thank you for wisdom.
Thank you for parents.
Thank you for love.
Thank you for kindness.
Thank you for humility.
Thank you for peace.
Thank you for prosperity.
Say thank you in advance for what's
already yours is how I live my life.
That's why I,
why I am one of the reasons why I am
today.
Say thank you in advance for what is
already yours.
True desire in the heart for anything
good is God's proof to you.
Sit beforehand to indicate that it's
yours all ready.
I'll say it again.
True desire in the heart,
that itch that you have,
whatever it is you want to do,
that thing that you want to do to help
others into,
to grow and to make money that desire,
that itch,
that's God's proof to you.
Sit beforehand or ready to indicate that
it's yours and anything you want,
good you can have
so claim it.
Work hard to get it when you get it,
reach back.
Pull someone else up.
Each one.
Teach one.
Don't just aspire to make a living
and aspire to make a difference.
Every failed experiment is one step
closer to success.
You've got to take risks and I'm sure
you've probably heard that before,
but I want to talk to you about why
that's so important.
Okay,
I got three reasons and then you can up
your iphone
first.
You will fail at some point in your
life,
except it,
you will lose,
you will embarrass yourself,
you will suck at something.
There's no doubt about it.
Okay.
I know that's probably not a traditional
message for a graduation ceremony,
but hey,
I'm telling you,
embrace it because it's inevitable.
And I should know in the acting
business,
you fail all the time.
Early on in my career,
I auditioned for a part in a broadway
musical,
perfect role for me.
I thought,
except for the fact that I can't sing.
So I'm in the wings,
I'm about to go onstage,
but the guy in front of me,
he's singing like,
like,
like Pavarotti.
He's
just
gone on and on and on and I'm just
shrinking and getting smaller and
smaller.
So when you say,
Oh,
thank you very much,
thank you very much in it,
you will,
you'll be hearing from us.
So I come out with my little sheet music
and it was,
it was,
uh,
jess,
my imagination by the temptations.
That's what I came up with.
So I hand it to the,
the,
the accompany us.
And,
uh,
she looks at it and looks at me and
looks at it,
the director,
and he's was like,
hi.
So I,
I start,
you know,
I'm going to sing.
I'm like,
say again,
can away with me
and then not saying anything.
So I'm thinking I'm getting better.
I started getting into it.
Yes ma'am.
Yeah.
Rania thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much Mr. Washington.
So I assumed I didn't get the job,
but the next part of the audition he
called me back the next party.
The audition is the acting part of the
audition.
You know,
I'm like,
Hey,
okay,
maybe I can't sing,
but I know I can act.
So they pair me with this guy.
And again,
I didn't know about musical theater and
musical theater is big so they can reach
everyone that all the way in the back of
the stadium.
And I'm more from a realistic,
naturalistic kind of acting where you,
you know,
you actually talked to the person next
to you.
So I the,
I don't know what my line was.
My line was will hand me the cup and his
line was,
well,
I will hand you the cup.
My idea,
the cup would be there to be handed to
you.
Yeah,
I see,
I see.
Okay.
Should I give you the cup back?
Oh yes.
He said,
give it back to me because you know that
is my cup and it should be given back to
me.
I didn't get the job,
but here's the thing.
I didn't quit.
I didn't fall back.
I walked out of there to prepare for the
next door edition and the next door
audition and the next door audition.
I prayed,
I prayed and I prayed.
But I continue to fail and fail and
fail,
but it didn't matter because you know
what,
there's an old saying,
you hang around the barbershop long
enough.
Sooner or later you're going to get a
haircut
so you will catch a break.
And I did catch a break
last year.
I did a play called fences on Broadway.
If someone talked about it,
won the Tony Award,
and I didn't have to sing by the way,
but here's the kicker.
It was at the court theater.
It was at the same theater that I failed
that first audition 30 years prior
point is,
and I'll pick up the pace.
The point is,
every graduate here today has the
training and the talent to succeed,
but do you have the guts to fail?
Here's my second point about failure.
If you don't fail,
you're not even trying.
I'll say it again.
If you don't fail,
you're not even trying.
My wife told me this great expression to
get something you never had.
You have to do something you never did.
Les Brown is a motivational speaker.
He made an analogy about this.
He says,
imagine you're on your deathbed and
standing around your deathbed are the
ghosts representing your unfulfilled
potential.
The ghost of the ideas.
You never acted on the ghost of the
talent you didn't use,
and they're standing around your bed
angry,
disappointed,
and upset.
They say,
we,
we came to you because you could have
brought us to life.
They say,
and now we have to go to the grave
together.
So I ask you today
how many goals they're going to be
around your bed.
When your time comes,
you go west,
you,
you've invested a lot in your education
and people had invested in you.
And let me tell you the world needs your
talents and does it ever,
I just got back from Africa like two
days ago.
So if I'm rambling on it's cause I'm jet
lag.
I just got back from South Africa.
It's a beautiful country.
But there are places there with terrible
part of it.
Poverty that need help in Africa is just
the tip of the iceberg.
The Middle East needs your help.
Japan needs your help.
Alabama mujer help Tennessee needs your
help.
Louisiana needs your help.
Philadelphia need your help,
the world.
The world needs a lot and we needed from
you.
We really do.
We need it from you young people.
I mean I'm not speaking for the rest of
us up here,
but I know I'm getting a little grayer.
We needed from you.
The young people cause remember this.
So you got to get out there.
You got to give it everything you've
got.
Whether it's your time,
your,
your talent,
your prayers or your treasures.
Because remember this,
you will never see a u haul behind a
hearse.
Okay,
I'll say it again.
You will never see a u haul behind a
hearse.
You can't take it with you.
The Egyptians tried it
and all they got was robbed.
So the question is what are you going to
do with what you have?
I'm not talking about how much you have.
Some of you are business majors.
Some of you are theologians,
nurses,
sociologists.
Some of you have money,
some of you have patience.
Some of you have kindness,
some of you have loved,
some of you have the gift of long
suffering.
Whatever it is,
whatever your gift is,
what are you going to do with what you
have
right now?
Here's my last point about failure.
Sometimes it's the best way to figure
out where you're going.
Your life will never be a straight path.
I began at Fordham University as a
premed student.
I took a course called the CARC cardiac
morphous.
I still can't see it.
It's called cardiac,
cardiac morphogenesis.
I couldn't read it.
I couldn't say it,
I sure couldn't pass it.
So then I decided to go into pre law
then journalism and with no academic
focus,
my grades took off in their own
direction.
Yeah,
down.
I was a 1.8 gpa one semester and the
university very politely suggested that
it might be better to take some time
off.
I was 20 years old,
I was at my lowest point and then one
day,
and I remember the exact day,
March 27th,
1975 I was helping my mother and her
beauty shop.
My mother owned a beauty shop up in Mt.
Vernon,
and then there was this older woman who
was considered one of the elders and the
town and I didn't know her personally,
but I was looking in the mirror and
every time I looked in the mirror I
could see her behind me and she was
staring at me.
She just kept looking at me.
Every time I looked at it,
she kept giving me these strange looks,
so she finally took the dry off ahead
and sets to some,
she said something I'll never forget.
First of all,
she said,
somebody give me a piece of paper,
give me a piece of,
she said,
young boy,
I have a prophecy,
a spiritual prophecy.
She said,
you are going to travel the world and
speak to millions of people.
Now Mind You,
I'm 20 years old.
I'm flunked out of school.
In fact like a wise ass.
I'm thinking to myself,
maybe she's got something in that
crystal ball about me getting back into
school next fall.
But maybe she was onto something because
later that summer,
while working as a counselor,
the Ymc camp and Connecticut,
we put on a talent show for the campers
and after the show,
another council that came up to me and
ask,
had you ever thought about acting?
You're good at that.
So when I got back to Fordham that fall,
I got in and I changed my major once
again for the last time and then the
years that followed just as that woman
prophesies.
I have traveled the world and I have
spoken to me,
tons of people through my movies,
millions who up until this day couldn't
see me.
I owe who were up till this day.
I couldn't see while I was talking to
them and they couldn't see me.
They could only see the movie.
They couldn't see the real me.
But I see you today
and I'm encouraged by what I see
and I'm strengthened by what I see
and I love what I see.
One more page and I'll shut up.
Let me conclude with this one final
point and actually the president kind of
brought it up.
It has to do with the movie
Philadelphia.
She stole my material
many years ago.
I did this movie called Philadelphia.
We filmed some of the scenes right here
on campus.
Philadelphia came out in 1993 most of
you are probably still in diapers.
Some of the professors too.
That cracked me up,
but it was a good movie you rented on
Nick.
Nick,
what do you call it?
Netflix.
It's good movie.
Renton.
I get 23 cents every time you run it,
please.
True
there.
Rent,
rent,
rent it.
Netflix.
Tell your friends too.
It's about a man played by Tom Hanks
who's fired from his law for him because
he has aids.
He wants to sue the firm,
but no one's willing to represent him
until the homophobic ambulance chaser
lawyer played by yours truly takes on
the case.
In a way.
If you watch the movie,
you'll see everything I'm talking about
today.
You'll see what I mean about taking
risks or being willing to fail because
taking risk is not just about going for
a job.
It's also about knowing what you know
and what you don't know.
It's about being open to people and two
ideas
in the course of the film,
the character I play begins to take
small steps,
small risks.
He's very,
very,
very slowly begins to overcome his fears
and I feel ultimately his heart becomes
flooded with love
and I can't think of a better message as
we send you off today to not only take
risks,
but to be open to life,
to accept new views,
and to be open to new opinions,
to be willing to speak at a commencement
had one of the best country Becka,
the universities in the country.
Even though you're scared stiff.
While it may be frightening,
it will also be rewarding because the
chances you take the people you meet,
the people you love,
the faith that you have,
that's what's going to define you.
So members of the class of 2011 this is
your mission.
When you leave the friendly confines of
Philly.
Never be discouraged,
never hold back.
Give everything you got
and when you fall throughout life.
And remember this fall forward.